I mean I think when ever you have an IP
or like a book series that is so beloved
by a fanbase you have to you know take
that take that on board and realize that
you know it's this is kind of a handle
with care' that because there are just
differences of interpretation and people
are emotionally attached to different
things and people really care you know
including us about these universes and
IPS that they're attached to we just
have to commit to making the best game
we can within the context of our
interpretation of the law and like it's
more important that a lot of people
really love it then that absolutely
everybody thinks it's okay
the danger of adaptation is being too
conservative and being overly reverent
because I think that's it's safe in some
respects but I think you you walk a path
in which you create something that is
dull and doesn't work in the medium
you're creating a forward
[Music]
with this 1951 letter to Collins
publishing house jr. our Tolkien
expressed his desire to create a fantasy
universe of interconnected stories and
myths
during the author's life numerous
illustrators poets and filmmakers made
their own interpretation of middle-earth
but at the time of tokens death in 1973
videogames were only a kernel of what
they are now neither he nor fans of his
work could have predicted the impact his
world would later have on the
interactive medium like many licensed
properties Tolkien's world has a spotty
history of video game adaptations blur
the Rings license spans almost every
genre from third-person action to
real-time strategy to an RPG inspired by
Final Fantasy 10 the entries also vary
drastically in terms of quality with
some great and others downright awful
this is due in large part to the Lord of
the Rings license changing hands so many
times it's gone from interplay to
Vivendi to Sierra to Electronic Arts
before finally reaching Warner Bros
which also controls the film property
rights the Lord of the Rings license has
resided there ever since 2009 several
Studios tackled the license under Warner
Bros releasing video games such as our
Lawrence quest middle-earth defense and
war in the north all three of these were
forgettable timid steps and didn't
garner much praise but then it was
monolith productions turn the studio has
an eclectic portfolio since its founding
in 1994 with games such as the matrix
online condemned fear and Gotham City
Impostors running the gamut of videogame
sensibilities and of course later this
week it's releasing Middle Earth shadow
of war the sequel to one of the best
games to come from 2014
but when monolith first got the chance
to work with middle-earth in 2012 these
self-proclaimed Lord of the Rings geeks
were eager if also a little bit nervous
they were all too cognizant of the
property's spotty history in games and
knew they needed to do something
different than the studio's that came
before them at the time games such as
League of Legends and dota 2 were
flourishing in the genre we know as
multiplayer online battle arenas or
MOBAs for short with such a rich cast of
heroes villains and magical beings the
Lord of the Rings seemed tailor-made for
MOBAs so monolith
set to work on guardians of middle-earth
it would be the first of three games set
in Tolkien's world and five years later
only days before the release of their
third we traveled to Kirkland Washington
to talk to monolith about the challenges
of adapting the Lord of the Rings of
making a licensed video game in general
and how their middle-earth entries are
leaving their own legacy in Tolkien's
wait
I guess my history with middle-earth
goes back to four so my grandma was a
teacher so she was giving me books all
the time from when I was tiny and the
Hobbit was like the second book she ever
gave me and so I just loved it and
devoured that and then immediately after
read Lord of the Rings and then read it
again and again and again you know right
through to my teenage years and then
devoured every other epic fantasy book
ever that was available through from the
late 70s through to pretty much the
present I grew up loving the books I
read The Hobbit when I was probably 7
years old and then the Lord of the Rings
trilogy a few years after that and loved
all the illustrations that were done for
the series you know all the Lord of the
Rings contents so I love John Howe Allen
Lee the Hildebrandt's it's really hard
to balance because at the core the
number one thing is you have to make a
great game but you have to make a great
game that is incredibly respectful of
the source material but more
specifically talking about you know
taking the lore and then expanding it
there is that authenticity component but
we always are asking ourselves the
question of could this exist in the
world and how do we justify these things
existing in the world I think everything
is reviewed by Warner Brothers but also
middle-earth enterprises like every line
of dialogue goes through them come to
see
you know the story outlines are reviewed
and we get feedback and respond to that
you know there's always a big question
when we want to use a famous character
from the original IP we have Gollum you
know like any relationship when you're
developing it there's there's that
period where you're developing trust and
you're trying to understand what the
other party you know thinks is important
and you're trying to communicate what is
important to you and the team even more
so after the success of shadow of Mordor
I think that gave them a level of trust
in how much we love the law and how
we're sort of really genuine in trying
to do the best job we can some extent
it's not canon like we've changed things
on the timeline it is another story that
exists alongside the books and the
movies so it's really striking that
balance like any good adaptation has to
do of telling your own story but really
trying to capture what's strongest about
the source material as well I was not
one of those kids who read it when I was
really really young you know I kind of
came to it later in life you know so in
my 20s
it's interesting now I have kids
and we just we finished The Hobbit last
year and we just worked our way through
fellowship and so it's kind of
fascinating to see him experience that
for the first time it's a good reminder
of just sort of you know what happens in
with adaptation and just sort of that
things exist differently every time
you're recreating this story in a
different medium it pacing changes
character emphases changes all of those
things as a moba guardians of
middle-earth didn't require much
narrative direction it was a mash-up of
heroes fighting each other with very
artificial rules using powers and
abilities loosely tied to Peter
Jackson's movies but when it came time
for monolith to leave guardians of
middle-earth behind it was faced with a
new challenge how do you actually add a
new chapter to tokens universe how do
you flesh out a fantasy world created at
a time when video games barely existed
how do you put a real lasting stamp on
the Lord of the Rings model that's
response of course was shadow of mortals
you don't get that many opportunities in
a lifetime to work in a beloved wills as
middle-earth and the focus is Mordor and
you know not that much has been written
about Mordor you you read Lord of the
Rings and there are a few conversations
between orcs here and there you go to
Mordor but the orcs are this kind of
unknown population and that's where we
really dive in and we get to create this
culture and civilization around the orcs
and we put this undead man fighting this
war having to form alliances with orcs
and battle against them and it it gives
us the opportunity also to create you
know new stories in in in this world
that we really all love you know
looked at you know Sarah Manzarek hi
slaughtering and getting into this fight
with the orcs of Mordor as they're
carrying merry and pippin or all the
orcs turning on each other and
slaughtering each other in Karratha
angle when Sam's going to rescue Frodo
and just think that being able to get
these guys to turn on each other kind of
being the spark that sets off that chaos
that seemed like a really interesting
angle we spend a lot of time ensuring
that the leathers and the clasps and the
armor and all of these elements are
relative to the time period and then
when it comes to the environments it's
the same thing we do an incredible
amount of research we do on location
shoots to ensure that things are
authentic and look realistic and then
the other thing we looked at is the
number of times in both the books and
the movies it teases this idea of what
would have happened if Boromir got the
ring of power what would have happened
if Galadriel had taken the ring off
Frodo and we'd had dark Galadriel
so that teasing of someone with heroic
goals but tempted down the road of using
power and kind of fighting the Dark Lord
head-to-head was a really interesting
ideas it's one thing to create a
narrative that fits within the legacy of
middle-earth it's another to make a fun
game set within that world as well but
with shadow of Mordor and its sequel
monolith wanted to do something more it
wanted to tie its story and gameplay
together it wanted to give players the
chance to pull their own story out of
the one the team had put so much effort
into crafting enter the Nemesis system
in you got your bank just mine yeah it
was one of the most innovative mechanics
of 2014 allowing enemy AI to adapt to
your actions remember your encounters
and act accordingly in the future if an
orc kills you he'll be promoted fight
him again later on and he'll have the
scars to show for it anyone who's played
shadow of Mordor can have their own
unique worst enemy with fears habits and
memories of their own the Nemesis system
is a massive effort across multiple
teams and so I think the first thing is
that we just have to ensure that there's
really good and right
communication between the key players so
the design group our realization group
that does all the cameras and some of
the animations our animation group a
concept group our character group that's
building the content because I think the
seed of it a lot of it really was in
sports games
I started off working on EA sports games
and sports games and sports in general
not to sports video games are actually
really good at creating dynamic
narratives around the interaction of
these different characters well here are
the New England Patriots one win away
from the second perfect season in NFL
history taking on a Giants team that
started o into this season
winners of 10 straight on the road and
they come rolling into this game with a
lot of confidence and think I've always
really liked in sports seasons as well
is you know you've got this beginning
you've know you've got this escalation
of drama that comes up through the
finals you know you've got the sort of
this epic climax in the Super Bowl or
whatever so there's a narrative
structure to it but there's a lot of
different ways that it can go along the
way and there's a lot of different
individual rivalries and personalities
so in a lot of ways the dynamic
commentary in in sports games and so on
a keeping track of what you've done and
then when two teams meet again later of
calling back to that is is really
powerful taking those ideas of a dynamic
narrative and these procedural
characters and putting them into an
action-adventure that was really
exciting when you remove the other sort
of seed of it is going back again to pen
and paper role-playing games where they
are always dynamic and the most
memorable characters are the you know
the guy who started as a random NPC that
you met on the fly but he managed to get
the last hit in and and there's always
more memorable and more meaningful than
whatever the crafted narrative that the
dungeon master wants to tell you is we
really are trying to create stories and
emotional connections to these
characters so when there is a betrayal
or when you lose what someone you were
sort of attached to or when you finally
get revenge it's a big emotional moment
so you know we've learned so much and
we've been doing this for six years now
and I still I think just at the
beginning
what the possibilities are for where we
could take it in the future
when you look at someone's intention or
someone's motivation and two people can
have very different different viewpoints
about you know what they were trying to
accomplish it lives on beyond the
experience rather than something that
like okay I've experienced that
completely digested it and never have to
think about it again I think that's
that's probably a monk of failure you
know in a lot of ways that's what we've
tried to avoid we really want to put in
as much content as possible that will
really excite and motivate conversation
and debate it's ironic that when trying
to make a game based in the most famous
fantasy world ever imagined the members
of monolith decided to shy away from a
traditional narrative rather than draw
from something that happened in
Tolkien's books or Peter Jackson's
movies or any of the numerous
adaptations that have emerged from
middle-earth over the years monolith
decided to go a different route to make
the players the storytellers it's
impossible to say what Tolkien would
have thought about Lord of the Rings
video games he was famously critical of
most illustrations and film scripts he
had the chance to see before he died and
video games at least most of the time
are inherently made to be fun
but regardless Middle Earth shadow of
Mordor and shadow of war are reminders
of that letter Tolkien sent to his
publisher that desire to create an
interconnected world that millions of
people could share when tasked with the
challenge of bringing the most beloved
fantasy story to life and adding to that
legend monolith solution was simple let
players tell this chapter themselves
[Music]
you